تستعد العاصمة الأوكرانية
لأسوأ نقاط التفتيش بأكياس الرمل للقوات المسلحة
مكدسة أمام مكتب رئيس البلدية
وسط كييف ولا توجد
قوات روسية في كييف الآن
بحسب رئيس البلدية لكن كانت
هناك معارك ضدهم ورئيس البلدية
يقول أه إن مجموعات كبيرة  من
المخربين الروس الذين تم تدميرهم بين عشية وضحاها
في القلب المادي ، ثورة أوكرانيا عام 2014
في ميدان ، الشوارع
مهجورة وكان هنا قبل ثماني سنوات
بالضبط انتفض المواطنون الأوكرانيون
ضد حكومة
موالية لروسيا رئيسًا مواليًا لروسيا وأطاحوا به
وهذا شيء
الذي اشتكى منه الرئيس بوتين لسنوات حتى
الآن
، تنزل قواته على المدينة التي تطوقها
في محاولة لإسقاط هذه
الحكومة
واستبدال الرئيس
بدمية ستجيب للرئيس بوتين
الآن بعد أربعة أيام من هذا الغزو الروسي.
دليل على
محاولة روسيا تطويق هذه المدينة وتقاتل
في كل اتجاه حول أعمدة من
الدخان  تحديد مناطق
القتال الأكثر شدة التي
تعيش في هذه المدينة هذه الأيام ليس
لأصحاب القلوب الضعيفة
بينما نحن في الخارج مباشرة في إشارة إلى
طفرة عميقة أخرى تخترق الصمت
أسفل الميدان في أنفاق
مترو المدينة والتي تعمل أيضًا  ملاجئ القنابل ،
أصبحت شرايين المدينة
مهجورة أيضًا ، مما زاد
من حدة الغرابة التي حافظ
عليها كييف لفترة أطول من
بعض التوقعات الأكثر خطورة والتي
شهدت سقوطها في غضون 24 إلى 48 ساعة ،
وقد نما التفاؤل مع
عدم قدرة الروس على اتخاذ أي شيء حقيقي.  السيطرة هنا
ولكن الجميع يعرف أنه من السابق لأوانه
الحصول على أي ثقة أليكس ماركوود cnn
keeve